pour 270 contre
265 l'Assemblée nationale a
adopté en conséquence le projet de loi
est
rejeté prochaine séance demain à 9h
question orale sans débat la séance est
levée ce texte comportait trop de trop
de contradictions c'est un texte qui se
voulait un texte de fermeté au départ
qui malheureusement avait été durci
considérablement par le Sénat totalement
vidé de sa substance ici par l'ile
gauche de la de la majorité qui n'avait
donc plus aucun intérêt avec une mesure
une mesure totalement inacceptable à nos
yeux c'était ce droit à la
régularisation qui aurait entraîné des
régularisation massive cette seule
disposition elle est à nos yeux
totalement inacceptable la France a pas
besoin de plus d'immigration elle a
besoin de moins d'immigration nous avons
donc vter cette motion de rejet nous
sommes ravis que cette motion est
abouti comme je me'y suis engagé hier je
déposerai dès demain une proposition de
loi dont je ne doute pas qu'elle sera
transpartisane et très certainement
accepté avec soulagement par la majorité
présidentielle le groupe parlementaire
de la France insoumise est extrêmement
heureux que cette motion de rejet a été
votée par l'Assemblée nationale et donc
est rejeté le texte dès le début de
l'examen à l'Assemblée nationale parce
que d'abord nous allons épargner au pays
de semaines de discours xénophobe et
raciste et je crois que ça va aider à
mieux respirer dans ce pays que de ne
pas avoir ces débats qui se tiendront à
l'Assemblée nationale ça c'est la
première chose la deuxième chose qui
nous semble importante c'est que avec le
rejet de cette loi dès le début de son
examen le pouvoir ferait bien de se
rappeler qu'il existe un parlement dans
ce pays et que le Parlement peut tout à
fait voter contre puisqu'ils sont
minoritaires à l'Assemblée nationale
c'est l'échec d'un gouvernement qui
depuis des mois pass en force avec des
493 méprisant l'Assemblée nationale
c'est l'échec de Gérald daranin un
ministre qui n'avait ni vision ni cap un
ministre qui s'est fait copie des idées
d'extrême droite qui a repris leur
proposition qui a repris leur mot c'est
la sanction de la duplicité du ministre
de
l'Intérieur ministre de la droite la
plus dure au
Sénat ministre de la compromission à
l'Assemblée
nationale
c'est au fond
l'épuisement du en même temps c'est un
rendez-vous manqué sur une question
importante pour les Françaises et les
Français je trouve que ce n'est pas très
digne de voir l'extrême droite et
l'extrême gauche faire la fête ensemble
et je pense pas que ce soit aujourd'hui
un bon moment pour notre démocratie
parlementaire il y avait du travail nous
avions de semaines de travail pour
parler d'un sujet qui intéresse les
Français et aujourd'hui nous en avons
été privés nous avons été privés de nous
interpeller priv de nous contredire
privé de voter je le regrette et tout ce
que je souhaite c'est que le
gouvernement poursuive parce qu'il peut
le faire dans sa volonté d'apporter des
réponses au problèmes de l'immigration